a modern woman is someone who can
balance their work and family life
someone who is
willing to grow with time
um yeah that's what a modern woman is
okay go ahead
wow a modern woman is and actually from
the guys I want to know if you date
modern women that's the second question
yeah well
it's it I mean most virtually all women
you know in the western world now
under a certain age are modern women to
various degrees
um I think that modern women are
impacted and influenced whether or not
they classify themselves as such by
feminist ideology
um and a lot of the
trappings of modern society and culture
um some are some adopt it all wholesale
some are more resistant but overall it's
influenced and permeated through Society
over the last few decades in a lot of
ways and I'm sure we'll talk about that
okay do you date modern women
yeah I guess okay okay go ahead
um I think modern women is
agree with what you say
also
and women are now
based upon female rap culture so a lot
of I get my own [ __ ] love Independent
Women
um I can do what I want and all of this
kind of stuff
um so I think the main key word is like
this sense of independency okay so yeah
a modern woman there's a million sub
categories to that there's the corrupt
there's the stuck in the past and old
tradition and there's the ones that have
evolved
yeah I'll say nothing all right
all right so mother women in my opinion
yeah whom they're independent they make
their own money oh I've got BMW I got my
own house yeah boom so I don't need no
man yeah and then they throw their box
around tell them yeah
yeah the vagina they throw their vagina
around yeah and what they do is they
sleep with certain types of guys yeah in
their prime years and then when they've
collected a lot of baggage and they're
out of their Prime and their value is
dropped they want to get with a good guy
Russell Wilson type and then they think
that their value is still high when it's
low it's dropped significantly rough you
know what I'm saying so so this is what
I think are you saying that women's
value is based on on who they sleep with
no no not necessarily not necessarily
that it's based on a lot of things
there's a lot of things okay okay like
age like the baggage mental and physical
you've collected foreign
woman yeah do I sleep with them yeah
I'll sleep with them but like girlfriend
like commitment it has to be like you
know some kind of Traditional Values
there because boy modern women can be a
headache in it like real talk but anyway
that's it okay Auntie Jenny I think
modern women are
women on the age of 30 over independent
influenced by social media
and
sport barrettes who can't shut their
legs and use their brains okay
um go ahead what do women now are women
that are trying to complete with
masculine energy feminine energy
completely they they go together a lot
someone said it I don't know who said it
said about the whole rap culture the
whole women can do it by themselves and
the whole like you understand stop
buying a house if you collect of your if
your credit score is poor you're not
going to get able to get a mortgage a
lot of women are forgiven they could go
out there but have the masculinity
collect their souls and then come back
and think a man's gonna value them sadly
enough a man's not the value for that so
you have to be yourself you have to be
independent to a degree but not in the
case of being a short chain you're
getting a short way to get where you
need to get to okay
go ahead and make sure you put bring the
mic to your mouth yeah there you go in
my opinion I'd say
it's a lot of whoa these modern women
they're trying to be like men
but it's like men and women are
different if you really being honest you
know what I'm saying and then a lot of
people aren't living their raps they get
me they think they're looking at cardi B
they're looking at Jada waders they're
looking at Beyonce's but brother you're
not in that 10 so just you get me
yourself humble yourself and be real so
I just feel like
but
I guess we're gonna dive into it proper
okay
I agree with you like to a point but
then I think modern women is abroad
statement because you've got different
types of modern women you got some that
are going out there
working getting their bag but then
they'll be committed at home looking
after their man doing everything I mean
so
it's two types modern women oh I think
it's an approach statement is this the
one do you date them
are we defining modern women as uh I'm
asking what you would Define what I
would do yeah how would you describe a
modern woman I don't know because uh
like a lot of you guys say the times
have changed right so if the times have
changed then what you would Define that
as is also very different than what my
mom or my grandma would have been back
then they might have been my mom might
have been a little more Progressive than
you know what you would consider modern
what I we'll consider modern today
um the everyday woman if I'm looking at
numbers from around the globe if I'm not
just looking at my little bubble that
I'm in like in London or somewhere
um yeah modern women are people haven't
changed people think they've changed
because they like Auntie said they're in
um social media bubbles they think that
things are different than they are but
they've never been to cities and
countries where it's very much the same
as it's always been so modern women
Modern Men same thing it really hasn't
changed by date yeah of course
um
I don't think
that the average person is
caught up with what media and social
media has put out so do I think that
people go like you know everyone's like
you were saying men and women are
different I think most of the world
still agrees with that from where I've
been where I've seen I think they still
agree with that so uh yeah put your date
of course yeah yeah okay easily Alex
uh the Modern Woman is a walking
contradiction so they are
generally narcissists and they are the
first women in I think probably most of
history that they tend to destroy what
they love and Chase what they hate uh
they have a number of things they want
but generally I think the modern woman
doesn't want to love I think the modern
woman wants to feel more than anything I
have a question for you who hurt you
do you say the same thing when women say
men are trash you said you say the same
thing okay who broke your heart sister
are you gonna mend it do you have a
response to that Alex who hurt me yeah
yeah I'd do the Hutton
maybe it's karma then
[Laughter]
what is the Modern Woman I think there
are different forms of a modern woman
but I think a lot of it now is to do
with money morals go out the window in
replacement for money and I often look
at people and what they're flaunting and
think is basically prostitution like
you're saying you'll do this give this
in return for a bag I don't understand
that like if you're going to have sex
with someone do it because you want to I
don't agree with doing it in favor for
material items but then on the other
side there's also other modern women who
exist coexist alongside them women who
are good women they've also had to
obviously move with the times and become
independent but they're also taking care
of all the other traditional aspects at
the same time that's the type of modern
woman that I rate as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible